bienvenidos a enlace norte américa desde
miami a continuación hablaremos sobre el
trabajo que se hace en el centro
nacional de huracanes situado en el sur
de la florida de los pronósticos para
este año en el atlántico y cómo se está
alistando la población para la temporada
ciclónica además recordaremos el paso
del huracán andrew por esta región hace
30 años que arrasó con gran parte del
sur de la florida y como esta la agencia
sirvió para que las autoridades y
ciudadanos aprendieran a prepararse para
la llegada de los huracanes en este
programa también abordaremos como el
cambio climático está afectando la
subida del nivel del mar y como los
gobiernos están impulsando políticas
para hacer frente a esta situación
aquí se encuentra el centro nacional de
huracanes es un verdadero búnker capaz
de soportar los efectos climáticos más
adversos en su interior decenas de
meteorólogos y científicos vigilan
minuto a minuto la formación de ciclones
la función del centro nacional de
huracanes por supuesto que es monitorear
preparar toda la información y por
supuesto llevar la informar a la
población haciendo que cada vez sean más
sofisticados esos pronósticos cuentan
con una tecnología cada vez más se
retraerá más confiable y por tanto sus
pronósticos son más efectivos no se
puede pronosticar con seguridad cuántos
huracanes habrá y dónde se formarán
durante la temporada que arrancó
oficialmente el 1 de julio y se
prolongará hasta el 30 de noviembre pero
los meteorólogos esperan que sea mucho
más activa de lo habitual las últimas
temporadas han sido generalmente activa
por encima de lo normal lo normal sería
alrededor de 14 tormentas tropicales y
estamos hablando de que por ejemplo esta
es de 14 a 21 lo que podemos esperar a
diferencia de otros fenómenos climáticos
los huracanes se pueden predecir con
varios días de antelación lo que da
cierto margen para los preparativos
algunos ciudadanos instalan ventanas de
impacto y se equipan con alimentos sobre
todo quienes vivieron la experiencia
hace tres décadas de la raza del huracán
andrew casi siempre tengo todo lo que
necesito pero esta vez fui busque mi
lista me hacía falta un poco de agua
baterías las linternas queremos tener
comida enlatada
comida que ya está preparada para tener
suficiente comida si es que en algún
momento lo necesitamos tener gloria sabe
muy bien la importancia de estar bien
preparado durante la temporada ciclónica
asegura que como ella la mayoría en el
sur de la florida no dije nada para la
improvisación ante el temor de un
huracán la preparación realmente es muy
muy muy importante a nosotros nos tocó
aprender esa lección hace 30 años con el
huracán andrew y yo creo y espero que
las personas no tengan que aprender una
lección así fue el 24 de agosto de 1992
cuando el huracán andrew llegó al sur de
la florida alcanzando la máxima
categoría las cinco con vientos
superiores a los 260 kilómetros por hora
devastó estas zonas urbanas de miami los
daños por la destrucción fueron
valorados en más de 27 mil millones de
dólares 54 personas perdieron la vida
hacía muchísimos años que un huracán no
pasaba por miami
y por lo tanto es una buena parte de la
población pasaba de los avisos de los de
los meteoros pero esta vez sucedido y a
partir de ese momento
creo que
creo que aprendimos la lección
y aprendimos la lección de estar
preparados y creo que que hoy en día
estamos mucho mejor preparados que que
hace 30 años los gobiernos también
aprendieron la lección y ya no se
escatima en recursos pero a miami ahora
le ha surgido otro problema el aumento
del nivel del mar provocado por el
cambio climático se estamos manejando
cifras que en el 2050 estamos viendo
alrededor de 60 a 90 centímetros de
aumento del nivel del mar y más allá en
el 2100 alrededor de 2 metros y un poco
más eso dejaría a cualquier comunidad
que queda la cosa completamente
desaparecida por eso en algunas ciudades
como miami beach están decididos a
combatir los efectos del calentamiento
global
parte del proyecto donde es posible es
subir la calle en varias área estamos
tratando de subir como podemos 6
pulgadas en una área quizá - en otra
porque levantando la calle el agua no
puede acumular y allí ahora también el
problema con subir la calle es que
muchos de los edificios de residencia
tiendas que están pegados tienen miedo
que si suben la calle el agua la va a
caer encima además se han instalado
bombas de agua para evitar las
inundaciones y se han subido las calles
de las zonas que ahora quedaban más
afectadas por las lluvias pero algunos
consideran que estas medidas no son
suficientes a largo plazo miramos cuáles
son las soluciones que se han propuesto
entonces se propone una muralla contra
el mar
pero que es una muralla o sea cuando se
empieza a subir el nivel de esa manera
la muralla se empieza a pudrir si hay
una tormenta el agua pasa por encima de
la muralla los expertos advierten que el
cambio climático también influye en la
formación de huracanes que dejan fuertes
inundaciones lo que podría provocar que
en pocos años algunas de estas zonas
queden completamente bajo el agua por
eso insisten en la necesidad de imponer
políticas medioambientales para frenar
estos fenómenos hasta aquí en la ac
norteamérica gracias por sintonizarnos y
recuerde que para ver de nuevo este
programa puede visitar nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom hasta la próxima